about your story let's talk about the
biden story in china
the one you liked here as well page five
i'm gonna do both of them at the same
time so if you want to go to page five
uh this is adam's story that he wants us
to cover which is a great story so biden
wants the second one is biden wants to
make
moving to the u.s from abroad easier and
cheaper by revamping the
immigration system it's a business
insider insider story
by the administration plans to rebuild
and expand the u.s legal immigration
system according to 46-page government
documents seen at the new york times dhs
plans to restore trust
in our legal immigration system the
draft documents outline plans to undo
president trump's effort to make
immigration more difficult expensive
slower
policies described in document would
help more people move to the us
including refugees asylum seekers
trafficking victims skilled workers
families of america living aboard abroad
and native americans born in canada the
abide administration administration
plans to rebound various programs and
immigration systems including h1b1 visa
program
for highly skilled workers uh and the
u.s visa program worked on generally
okay
documentary so what do you think about
this what do you think about this i
think making it easier
i think part of the problem and i think
part of the problem that
trump ran into was i know people are
going to say he wanted legal immigration
he wanted legal immigration he wanted to
build a beautiful wall
with a big beautiful door and that's
great and that's all good
but he under the underbelly the
undertone was that he was sort of
anti-immigrant
so that was what a lot of people were
offended by
what i think i'm look
we need to welcome immigrants in this
country immigrants are who make
america you're an immigrant okay my my
grandparents were immigrants from russia
yeah
russian ashkenazi jews that came over
here had nothing and made a
you know a living and made a life and
and i think the biggest thing who what
did reagan his most famous quote is we
want to be a shining city on a hill and
a beacon of hope
for the world i think that's where
america has lost his stature under trump
there was a
lot of good things that happened under
trump this isn't a trump hater
uh are you are you saying stats or you
spitting out
lines i'm saying stats or lines i'm just
saying this is my opinion here i think
number one we need to
stats disagree with you okay okay well
let me just tell me why
go ahead no i think show that obama
deported more people
than any other president in history of
america to mexico that's that's
that's that's a bit i'm talking
immigration overall
but no overall but immigration overall
the main issue
was from the mexican border we don't
have issues with people coming here from
you know iran or china or you know italy
there's a lot of people coming and not
leaving yeah
yeah we don't have a problem with that
the problem why people said uh
trump was anti-immigration was only one
country
and it's not one south or central
america that was the problem so when
you're talking about immigration
if you talk stats that's favor against
he did talk about [ __ ] countries and
having people coming from [ __ ] countries
you can't dispose
this isn't turning into a trump thing
this is more of a commentary on
immigrants
immigrants should be welcome to america
yes we want people that work hard
that pay their dues that want to make
something of themselves
but you can't beggars can't be true this
kind of a thing people are
we we want people to come to america and
there's some money behind this
tax revenue we do have social security
to pay for it baby boomers are getting
older
we need young people able bodies to be
working in america paying taxes that's
what we do
no one disagrees with america welcomed
immigrants there's a lot of people that
do disagree don't think so there's a lot
of
anti-community sentiment give me a name
there's a poll
stats there's a poll out there kai you
might want to pull this off
google it's stats give me stats
this is a stat that's not a stat that's
a poll opinion that's opinion
okay a poll is an opinion i'm asking
stats if you give stats
no one deported more people than obama
again i'm not trying to get political
here i'm talking about that
pro-immigration i get that so if i read
this article your business insider okay
look how they read it
look how they write this article you can
tell which way they lean just by the way
they wrote it
policies described in the document would
help more people move to the u.s
including
refugees asylum seekers trafficking
victims
skilled workers family of americans
living abroad and native americans
born in canada now if this was an
article written about trump you know
what that would say
he uh trump policies described and
document would force
families to split up with force the way
they're writing it as if it's like an
angel
uh biden is doing the greatest thing
look we know what's happening here
you want more votes it's exactly what
they want pelosi said i've always done
we should make votes at 16 years old you
want a 16 year old voting hey we should
get more people that are immigrants
undocumented people
to vote of course that's all political
this is a political plan
and biden won't even address the fact
that there is an issue going on in the
southern border so i think you lose a
lot of credibility when you're talking
about immigration
when you can't fix a pretty major
problem that we have going on right now
in this country
so the credibility is shot and people
welcome immigrants we've always done
that and i don't think immigrants care
about being welcome they just want the
opportunity to come here and be able to
work and do their thing
that's all they're looking for so look
you can't trust them i mean
it's a complete mess with what's going
on down there you know what i would say
about this guys
here's the following okay so to the to
the person that
is 43 years old has been living in u.s
for 25 years
parents came here and they've been here
for 25 years they're americans they've
lived in america more than they lived in
mexico
what are we waiting for with legalizing
these people what do we do we're talking
about the dreamers
yeah wholeheartedly what are
what are we doing like what what are you
doing like the
this is this is this has been part of
the these kids didn't do anything wrong
they were under 18 when their parents
came here
yeah you wanted to talk i don't
understand that concept and why
republicans won't agree to that i i
don't
by the way obama had a chance to do it
nothing happened what do you mean
because the republicans voted against it
but but you mean to tell me the last
four years democrats and republicans
whoever is in charge
should make it happen this is not a
republican or democrat oh it is
republicans hold them back 40 is
democrats i'm gonna say 60
republicans 40 democrats they've had
both both
house and the senate to be able to pull
this up how come you haven't done it how
come you haven't done it
half the time why [ __ ] doesn't get done
is because they over negotiate
when you over negotiate you go into
gridlock when you go into gridlock
nothing gets done
that's half the challenge that they got
you ask 75 different things that you put
in there
and the other part is like listen i'm
not doing this you're trying to pull in
25
minimum wage by 2025. i'm not agreeing
to this so these are the types of things
yeah they're trying to stick [ __ ] in
there
but but to me dude you've been living
here for 25 years you're not one you
don't want to make this person legal
how much taxes has this person paid
sales to how much tax does this person
let's just already flip that what now at
the same time you got a
criminal record hey felony you got all
that stuff i'm sorry different story
we have to figure that part out a clean
house as well but for that community
i don't i don't know and also here's
something
and i actually think trump was actually
pro this so this is this is actually me
giving trump credit
this h-1b visa program yeah these are
highly skilled workers these are some
are we losing them
from india from south korea pick a
country
goes to university learns to become an
engineer and then after
after they graduate you send them back
the only ones i would be very concerned
about
the only ones and i'm being that serious
with you the only ones i would be very
concerned about
are uh uh from china no china from china
and a bit of iran by the way and yeah
and i'm from iran yeah i would be very
concerned i would do
additional uh due diligence to see where
it's coming from you know what's
incredibly agree
did you watch that video kai sent two
nights ago or last night about africa
did you
see that basically bought africa china
basically bought africa they built a
the african union headquarters with 300
million dollars and
later on in the middle of the night
every night they're like why is our
system down
china was getting all the emails all the
data the employees
every office was wiretapped and they're
listing what africa is up to
what is their strategy man they they own
it and they they pay for all their
infrastructure right they
and that's a good segue into the next
door the craziest part that video though
was
with the furniture and how like in the
furniture there's wires and there's bugs
made custom into the furniture like how
crazy does that
i would be very very careful with
china and which family it's coming from
that would be me my own and it's
unfortunate to say this
in which family i i want to do more due
diligence of what your background is as
you're coming here i want to know where
you're coming from i want to know what
what you're most when you're coming to
america that's the only thing i'm a
little bit concerned with that part but
aside from that i mean i get it
you know i get the fact that uh when
talent comes here you go to our school
we train you and we send you back what
are we doing here let's keep you know
keep talent here yeah keep talents here
so that's
smart talented people no question about
it so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]